eine der großen herausforderung für
einen mars aufenthalt wird jetzt
angegangen
die versorgung mit lebensmitteln dafür
haben das deutsche zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr und das alfred wegener
instituts für polar und meeresforschung
ein gewächshaus entwickelt dass pflanzen
komplett künstlich wachsen lässt jetzt
wird es in der antarktis getestet und
wenn es klappt geht es danach direkt in
den weltraum das besondere an dem
gewächshaus jetzt wirklich vom feinsten
fiction herzlich willkommen
sind der marsianer haben wir gesehen wie
markwort sich ein gewächshaus auf dem
aufgebaut hat ohne die darin angebaute
nahrung hätte er nicht überleben können
auch für reale mars mission wird das
wohl generell gelten sie werden
wahrscheinlich nicht in der lage seien
genügend wasser und nahrung zu
transportieren um auf dem
lebensfreundlichen planeten zu überlegen
die kosten würden ins unermessliche
steigen
es müsste viel mehr frachtraum bereit
gehalten werden und mit dem zusätzlichen
gewichts auch viel mehr treibstoff wenn
aber wasser dort gewonnen werden kann
und nur samen und die technik zum anbau
dorthin transportiert werden müssen dann
reduziert sich dieser bedarf erheblich
und es werden aber und aber milliarden
kosten gespart deswegen wird zurzeit
fieberhaft daran geforscht wie wasser
dort gewonnen werden kann was keine so
große herausforderung darstellen dürfte
und wie pflanzen dort gezüchtet werden
können und das ist nicht ganz so einfach
bzw
besonders heikel geht es nämlich schief
muss die mission abgebrochen werden das
wäre fatal deswegen wird im moment
fieberhaft daran geforscht wie eine
solche nahrungsmittelproduktion aussehen
könnte
das deutsche zentrum für luft- und
raumfahrt dlr und das alfred wegener
instituts für polar und meeresforschung
haben jetzt ein gewächshaus entwickelt
das so auch auf dem mars eingesetzt
werden könnte dafür haben sie ein system
entwickelt bei dem die pflanzen komplett
künstlich ernährt werden sie werden mit
eigens dafür gebauten led lampen
beleuchtet und nicht in erde gepflanzt
sondern die wurzeln hängen frei in der
luft und werden mit wasser besprüht in
dem auch eine nährstofflösung enthaltene
dadurch werden die pflanzen komplett
keimfrei gezüchtet und das risiko dass
sie von krankheiten oder schädlingen
befallen werden ist nahezu null der co2
gehalt gescheitert mit speziellen
filtern reinl die luft von pilzsporen
und keinen und betreiben eine anlage zur
luft sterilisation mittels uv strahlung
damit können wir eine rein biologische
züchtung ermöglichen die ohne
insektizide und pestizide auskommt das
sagt projektleiter daniel schubert vom
dlr institut für raumfahrtsysteme alle
zehn minuten werden die wurzeln von
einem
nebel mit nährstoffen verhüllt und
nehmen so ihre nahrung auf durch den
erhöhten co2 gehalt wachsen die pflanzen
rund 30 prozent schneller und das led
licht wird auf jede pflanzenart
individuell abgestimmt das ist eine
mischung aus raum roten und weißem licht
dass das gewächshaus violett schimmern
lässt wenn der test gelingt bedeutet das
für eine mars-mission dass man dafür nun
konzentrierte nährstofflösung die samen
die technik und die behälter für die
pflanzen und das led-licht bräuchte für
dieses gewächshaus kommt jetzt also der
härtetest wird es in die antarktis
gebracht und dort in der nähe der
antarktis station neumayer 3 aufgebaut
ein jahr lang soll es beweisen dass es
in der lage ist die besatzung der
station mit frischem gemüse zu versorgen
gelingt dies wird eine mini-version des
gewächshauses sie jetzt auch in der
angriff mit gesetzt wird zur ipad zur
internationalen raumstation geschick
muss dort unter beweis stellen dass es
auch dort im weltraum funktioniert wir
halten euch natürlich auf dem laufenden
ob das marke mexx es funktioniert oder
ob es schwierigkeiten gibt wollte dazu
kein video verpassen dann sollten wir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter aber hier mit fünf verbissen
fakten über den mars der marsianer im
faktencheck mit der dlrg olo ging
daniela kuhr sehr sehr interessant wie
nah an der wirklichkeit der film
tatsächlich ist also einfach
draufklicken ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bislang geplant